brian great to see you this is uh start
with succession
i've seen that you said that you kind of
thought it was going to be a big hit
because you could feel the quality yeah
of the scripts but when it went as big
as it did have you ever experienced
anything quite like that in your career
uh the
debut of the last season
and at the royal festival hall
i walked on
being the eldest member i walk home
first
and the audience reaction was
astonishing
and i actually thought somebody had come
on behind me like something kind of you
know like some iggy pop or something
like that or mick jagger had walked on
behind me and i don't know there was
nobody there and i thought
this is weird
do you get a lot of people coming up
simply wanting them to you to swear
absolutely all the time all the time and
of course it's the easiest thing to say
do you do it of course
of course i mean
you know i love it
[Laughter]
the the great thing i think about you
brian is you said recently you've
reached the age of mid 70s and you don't
care anymore about saying what you think
about things and you talked about how
when you were younger you would temper
your words your opinions and stuff but
now you don't care we're in a very odd
place in society i think with this kind
of cancer culture mentality people
walking around on eggshells terrified of
expressing opinions because they're
getting fired they're losing jobs
they're getting shamed and abused and
vilified and so on what do you make of
where society is going what do we do
about it well it's a kind of modern day
mccarthyism
really
uh
it's a kind of raid on people's
sensibilities in order to kind of reduce
them
and make them
i don't know
there's so much hypocrisy involved yes
that the whole thing i mean i find the
whole thing completely hypocritical who
is the one you know there's a i mean i'm
not religious but there is a thing in
the the bible when it says lets him
without sin or he she without sin cast
the first stone and there seems to be a
lot of casting of stones and it's like a
virus you know elon musk calls it a woke
virus well that's weird
and it feels to me like what's ironic to
me is the people doing it they claim to
be liberals there's nothing liberal
about it no there's nothing it's the
opposite it's almost a form of fascism
it is total fascist yes it is you're
absolutely right it is total fascism and
people are behaving more and more and
and the
in the kind of hypocritical you see it's
hypocrisy again the hypocritical notion
of i'm being liberal but actually you
are being fascist yes and people should
just stop it and behave themselves i
completely agree and it's and again the
ironys fascism would be the one thing
they would all say is the thing they
hate most exactly and they're trying to
counter but in fact they're practicing
it themselves exactly and you're
absolutely right on that i just i i find
it appalling i really do when you see
what happened to someone like jk rowling
you spoke about i think one of your kids
brought you up to speed on what she'd
say and it was no women menstruate for
example and you were like what i don't
understand what all the fuss is about
and yet she was exposed to death threats
and all sorts of attempts to cancel her
and so on
again i just felt everyone's losing
their minds well i i couldn't understand
that whole thing at all you know man i
thought well this is this is not an area
i'm i
i am not necessarily permitted to tread
upon but at the same time i thought it
was okay there was something
deeply unjust about it you know i just
felt that and uh you know and it's
happening time and time again
and it's not only it's not only the
people who are canceled it's also the
people like their families like their
children like their parents like that
you know it has it has such
ramifications it's sort of it creates a
sort of like an earthquake situation
yeah
on jk rowling she was she said standing
up for women's rights we've got to a
strange place again where
politicians supreme court nominees
are struggling to say what a woman is
that they're too scared to say it's an
adult female yeah but the fear of the
mob well we've never examined you see
the point is we're beginning to examine
things that we have never hitherto
examined before particularly the the
relationship between men and women and
particularly the sexual relationship
between men and women and how that
relationship is operated and it
particularly affects
young men and women because they don't
know how or what or how or should they
express themselves in certain ways and
there's a kind of form of fascism
because i'm not done effect where they
they you know i i i you know there are
kids who just do not know how to
approach one another now
and it's well let's see they're so
scared well
yeah it's too scary but it's also we're
a lot to blame because we haven't
attended to it we haven't actually had
schools of study about how those what
those relationships when you talk about
study i mean i'm i'm incredibly
depressed by what's going on at
university
colleges
campuses around the world where you see
new york posted a piece about five
professors who all got cancelled and
it's happening all over the place
one of them was actually giving a
lecture given for 20 years where he
talked about the usage of offensive
language and to illustrate this in the
lecture he said some offensive language
and he got cancelled because people
didn't have the brain power to
understand what he was doing well this
is part of the virus and
and it kind of
i don't know it just makes people behave
in the most
idiotic insensitive and again as i say
hypocritical way you know they feel one
thing but they practice something quite
else what's the answer to it
i don't know i mean i i i it's a we're
not in a very sad place at the moment
really i think with what's going on both
in ukraine and what's been going on in
america especially in the last
seven years you know i mean it's just
been a very bad time and we're so
confused we just don't know what to
believe anymore because all our belief
systems are falling apart and so we're
we're like vigilantes we have vigilante
belief groups which is what i believe
the whole world culture is yes it's a
form of vigilante it is it is
mccarthyite it's exactly the same
mentality
rooting people out for in perceived
indiscretions
and then basically evaporating them from
society that's right and and there's no
we go why is the reason and of course
it's catching i mean uh
the the the it's catching a bit in my
business it catches because suddenly
projects i mean bill murray the other
day and a wonderful i mean he he made it
a mark and it was taken and away
as being offensive
and the picture he was making was
stop stop the whole thing now bill went
on see i think it was cnn and explained
himself i thought rather brilliantly
actually saying you know we le it's
about times of change
i lived and grew up in one time and i'm
meeting another time and it's very hard
to know how to approach that time
where do we go how do we come in where
where is the entryway to make a
conversation or just make even a joke
with one another well anyone anyone can
take offense in anything and they can
then weaponize the offense exactly and
that's where we've got ten it's almost
impossible to defend yourself because
the court of public opinion passes
verdict immediately that's right
let's turn to a happier thing okay you
went to lambda where you you attended
land of the great drama school my middle
son went there he's a young actor
and he remembered you going there and
doing a q a speech
and he said the most memorable thing
that you said was that you should always
carry a picture of yourself as a child
to remember to maintain childlike
enthusiasm exactly do you do that
yourself i do i i actually i keep it on
my phone hopefully it'll come up
there it is and it just came out i think
we've got it on that's it that's on your
phone you're showing me it here and
we've got it on screen
when you see that little little boy
have you lived up to every dream that
little boy had
i have to say pretty much
i have actually i i mean i i i recognize
the look i reckon that and i'm constant
and the look is always different on
every day but today is going you know
it's not bad
when you go to the stage did you ever
think you'd get to this stage of your
life and your career and you would
suddenly be in this monster hit
brilliantly written with amazing actors
all around you and everywhere you're
going they think you're mick jagger i
mean it's pretty amazing right yeah it's
kind of crazy i mean i think you know
i've been in this business now believe
it or not i have now entered the seventh
decade of being in this business amazing
you know and is this the highlight for
you yeah i have no question and it's and
it's sort of moved in that direction i
mean
the map of my life has been really
i think
i mean full of extraordinary tragedy and
heartbreak but really quite remarkable
and and and made me
very respectful and how like logan roy
are you in real life well as a father as
a father i have certain difficulties i i
i because i didn't have a father
and i think that's something
logan roy and have in common and the
difference between logan
we have a we are both disappointed with
the human experiment yeah we're deeply
disappointed with that but i'm an
optimist
i believe it will get better he isn't
now i've heard reports rumors that you
maybe think you're going vegan is that
right well i'm thinking of of going
plant life i mean i
the problem is i like the taste of
hamburgers
i i actually rather like that well
here's my here's my problem you know
there are some wonderful plant life
hamburgers and i couldn't tell the
difference
here's my problem my problem you talked
about hypocrisy earlier these are percy
pigs are you familiar with these i don't
know so they took them vegetarian
they're now taking them vegan and i've
got to do this to show you what we do
here play this
here's my problem they're making these
vegan percy pigs but they're pigs heads
yeah why would any vegan want to be seen
eating a pig's head whilst claiming to
be virtuous about animal welfare let me
give you the the the the scenario i
would say
so he looks at this or she looks at this
and she says ah pig
now a pig is a vegan
a pig is a natural vegan pigs they don't
eat meat they tend to but you're still
eating the pig's head yes but that's in
respect
brian i've got to leave you there what a
pleasure to see you thank you thank you
for fighting the cancer culture mob we
need more like you out there